Tổ thủ Mỹ, ông đồ nên tròm nghe em, em tặng thẩm mô đánh báo Iran phải nhánh trong Washington City
hành động của tặng công không thể thơm, sợm trước đây pháp hiểu trên mặt sâu trước, sâu, sâu,
không tròm dẫn lại của không kích và trong tâm hạnh nhận của Iran của trong sau của Mỹ, nhưng một lời cạnh báo,
lông thời nhận mạnh Mỹ không chấp nhận Iran, sâu hiểu của kia nhớn và cho rằng,
thời gian của định của giờ trước, tế Iran đảm cạnh dần.
Ông tròm chập viết nhiều lúc lượng hai con Mỹ trong độc còn nhóm đặc biệt, đầu sân bài đưa et,
ở bò hành linh cần đang áp sát Iran, hai con trụ Mỹ cũng đã sống nhận thủ Mỹ này,
phần nếu trước từng bú trên, cô vấn lạnh tổ tối kia Iran,
Ali Samp, Khan đi, cạnh báo mỏ hình đậu quốc sự và kìp Iran nhằm buộc tiêu vòng Mỹ,
i Seren và các độc mình cũng ổ họp, ngoài trụ Mỹ Iran đã bắt sợi chi thì không định,
được lượng bú trẳng Iran sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn sẵn đặc trạm lập tất, mỏ hình đậu với hạnh,
sẵn bất định ngọt khả năng đặt một thật hả nền công bằng và bị đậm, báo đạm không cộng của thiện nhân.
Căng thẳng Mỹ và Iran ra tăng trong buổi cạnh Washington tăng cường khiến sẽ quân sự tại chúng đông,
và phương tây chỉ trích mạnh mẹ chỉ dưới chân áp yếu tình của Tehran.
Liên mình cho ông dự kiến thảo lượng, các bạn pháp trường phạt mối và khả năng liệt lực lượng với đình kế mạng hoài rảo Iran,
và vẻng sách tổ trước khủng bố.